well boy who knew the storm over stormy
as in stormy Daniels and the paymon to
hurt and go away turns out the President
did remember this matter after long
insisting you knew nothing about this
matter and I had heard this before a lot
and I addressed it last night let me be
clear mr. president
how can you drain the swamp if you're
the one who keeps muddying the waters
you didn't know about that $130,000
payment to a pornstar I think it did
said you knew nothing about how your
former lawyer Michael Cohen handle this
until acknowledging today you were the
guy behind the retainer payment that
took care of this I'm not saying you're
a liar you're president you're busy I'm
just having a devil of a time figuring
out which news this thing let's just say
your own words on lots of stuff give me
shadow I'd say lots of pause I guess
you're too busy draining the swamp to
ever stop and smell the stink you're
creating that's your doing that's your
stink mr. president that's your swamp
pretty clear but a lot of you well
clearly ticked off Frank
on Facebook writes Neil you proved today
that you are leftist liberal and a [ __ ]
it will no longer listen to your show
ciao ciao
joyce writes what is the deal i've never
you go on such a tirade you need to be
shipped out bobby writes well you just
lost millions of trump supporters today
with your little rant on your president
enjoy your low ratings wait a minute
glenda on facebook we all know trump is
it perfect but man wait a pile-on
maybe we should go back and examine
every word that comes out of your mouth
Regina on Twitter Neil Cavuto is an ass
and a swamp creature well which is it an
answer Joey right so Cavuto shut the
hell up you're an idiot and not old
soldiers has this piece of I can't and I
can't say that my thoughts news just
bash POTUS really good they don't use do
not send me via Facebook that was it for
me won't watch you again Linda writes I
listened to his dribble I was astounded
Kabuto has become a true jerk today was
the last time I will use my electricity
to watch your fat face bad days
like I haven't heard that one before
Linda writes totally agreed with your
closing editorial sad to say many cannot
see past their blind devotion Trump
causes his own problems well a lot of
them Tim on Facebook writes your
commentary today in the last minutes of
your show nailed it and I'm a Republican
police says just watch you've totally
trash POTUS won't watch you again
Scott rides boycott Fox news until Neil
Cavuto is terminated hey wait a minute
that means fired
Julie shut up Neil don't you shut up
barb on Facebook you are a hundred
percent correct I love your commentary
and I love you Greg via Twitter cuz Ludo
is part of the RINO establishment always
has been and always will be Karen emails
acts like a rhino looks like a rhino
talks like a rhino fired at that fool
now how dare you call me that Karen
anyway didn't you know the camera adds
20 pounds ask Andy Rhino yeah and by the
way it's not Rhino like the animal its
Rhino
Rin Oh as in Republican in name only fat
chance
you knew that once together I blended
that Vanessa in New Paltz New York I
felt so bad for you when you returned
from open-heart surgery I have to tell
you I feel even worse you survived the
only did you write that can be yeah if
you think you could fall back on your
multiple sclerosis and other medical
issues to win by sympathy think again
you chubby fat challenge jump Fox might
keep you out of pity I do not and I will
not click alright Ken I'm putting it
down as a maybe on there but I think I
could win you over
tweeter in Iowa and all they say because
you've never gotten an interview with
Donald Trump wow what a vindictive
hateful cannot say that word you know
Shane via Twitter and you wonder why
President Trump it won't do your show
well actually I've had plenty of
interviews with Donald Trump over the
years probably dozens I just not asked
for or shown interest in a chat with him
as president now that does not mean I
still don't cover them I'm just not
interested in joining the conga line a
very good and talented folks eager to
interview
all do a great job every single one of
them there is little I could add so it's
not really personal it's just business
Clyde and Atlanta isn't buying it I
never heard you say a single good word
about this president would killed you
just once just once to mention the
amazing market run-up under his watch
actually cried I did and I think a lot
more than just once this markets the
bomb we are in a freaking stock bomb
cyclone some have a feeling that you
know this guy a video give back kill
it's got to be a slowdown here we don't
see it a lot of what the run we've seen
is based on you know lower regulations a
more positive environment another
milestone on the Dow today 25,000 now
for the markets it has been an historic
run and a lot of these guys might not be
big personal fans of Donald Trump but
they sure as heck are big fans of what
Donald Trump is cooking up big tax cuts
more than once or at my point with
showing all of that is to stress the
balance I try to apply covering this
president in any president any issue the
good the bad just because I'm not always
praising Donald Trump doesn't mean I'm
never drawn bored never trump or
whatever that means
can they be a Comcast thinks otherwise
you're the fake news never Trump ur the
president likes to warn it's all about
and you're fat too okay always the fat
thing I move on anyway fake news works
both ways candy so dis consistency every
fact I presented last night was real
every comment I used from the president
was his not my words his words word for
word not my tweets his tweet nothing was
faked everything I shared was real no
matter the Bob emails you're a smug
pompous windbag I hope that you croak on
that pork chop tonight wait a minute did
you know I'm having pork chops tonight
honey Toby in New York City generally I
find you hateful condescending and an
annoying dead ringer for the kid I used
to routinely beat up in middle school
but I'm drawn to you for some reason
last night might have proved why
good job beefcakes beefcakes by the way
is that you
anyway Sheila via Twitter this is what's
called fair and balanced Ingrid writes
I loved it right on good mood Oh Angela
tweets I'll start watching you Neal
keep reporting the truth Bob writes Neal
I hate to say it but you are spot-on
someone needs to tell the president that
having a great agenda and results are
negated by bizarre childish behavior it
is time for him to grow up and to think
about what he says now I'm not here to
provide lessons just facts just like
I've always said words matter and yes
tweets matter
I won't lecture you about eating a salad
for obvious reasons what I'm saying is
the president should be very careful
calling anyone else being fate so I'll
try to keep it real so I hope you have a
real good weekend and think twice at
that very nasty names on the fad thing
because I'm kind of vulnerable good
night